Our next guest is one of the most
famous radio personalities in the country.
His unfiltered tell-it-like-it-is candor
has even made him a radio Hall-of-Famer.
And now he's brought his raw honesty
to the television screen with his new show,
"Tha God's Honest Truth with Charlamagne Tha God."
And he is here today revealing a side of him
that you haven't heard,
but first, let's check this out.
Are we a society that's really meant for monogamy?
I'm willing to bet that it depends on
how attractive you are.
If you have an unfortunate face,
then you're more likely to be good and faithful.
What? Okay?
But there's attractive men who still believe in monogamy,
like me.
(audience applauds)
Please welcome Charlamagne Tha God!
(audience cheers)
I am...
Hello.
What's happening?
One of the things I really found interesting
in my research of you was that you have four kids.
Four daughters. Yes, I breed queens.
(audience applauds)
I have a 13 year old, a six year old,
a three year old, and the newborn.
So, we grew up differently-
different circumstances, different places and spaces-
but I think we're very connected on something
and I was curious as to why.
I don't want my kids on social media.
I just feel that this is what's right for me.
How come you feel that way?
I don't want my kids seeking validation from anybody
other than the people that truly, truly love them
'cause imagine growing up in the era that we grew up in
where, you know, your every single move
is broadcasted via social media.
Like, we gotta be allowed to make mistakes
and then it's that weird, awkward phase, right?
Like, I remember in sixth grade when I had,
like, glasses and the fanny pack
and my glasses used to always fall off my face
and they were crooked so when I took my school picture,
the glasses were crooked.
Like, I don't want kids getting a hold of that
and then I'm a meme for the rest of my life.
That's not the worst thing
they're gonna find out about you.
And you know that's probably gonna just
become a fashion trend the next day.
Maybe, but then it's really, for me,
it's just really the self-esteem thing.
I just don't think that people are meant to be
that connected.
Like, it shouldn't be thousands of people weighing in
on their opinion of you.
You'd think that doesn't get to you,
but it does chip away at you.
I don't think that any human being
is impervious to negative comments.
It's human nature to be hurt by those arrows.
And you ended up projecting that pain,
whether you realize it or not.
Like, you might, you know, take it in and then suppress it
and tell yourself that it doesn't bother you,
but you just go around projecting that pain and the hurt
on everybody else.
I agree.
So, it's impossible to take in all that negative energy
and then not project it, you know, to the world.
I miss the days when it was just talking about politics
and it wasn't so personal.
It's almost impossible though now, right?
Because now when you look at somebody's politics,
you think that is a indictment of what that person is about.
But I think that is because of the Trump era, right?
Like, when you saw racism and bigotry at the forefront
like you did,
you just assumed, "Okay, if you're a Trump supporter
then you're just naturally a racist and a bigot."
That's not always the case- maybe 75% of the time.
I just don't want to hate people for what they believe in
and I don't want to be hated for being who I am.
And I just-
Absolutely.
I'm gonna lean towards whoever I see
truly caring about the people.
And for me, that's neither party at this point.
So, you want it to be equal opportunity
and you want to fight for people.
I thought that's what America was about.
That's what they tell us, at least.
That's what's on the marquee, you know?
Freedom, justice, liberty, equality for all.
But you know, that's-
they've been doing some bad marketing for years.
(audience chuckles)
And that's why I don't mind having the conversations
and I say, "Bring it on,"
because you might learn something or reveal.
That is my biggest problem with, like, the dating app world.
Who can tell from a photograph who that person is
and how you're gonna connect with them?
I know it's a weird correlation- but I just think-
I don't know nothing about that.
I don't-
I couldn't even imagine trying to date in 2021
and having to be on dating apps.
Like, that's terrifying.
Well, 'cause you're talking about getting to know somebody
and the more we put everything in a technological veneer,
the less we're actually having that
engaged, peeling back the layers of the onion.
That's why what Mark Zuckerberg is doing with Meta
is so dangerous.
People are already living in, like,
this delusional alternate reality.
Now I can just create my own world.
Where the incentive to be something in life
if I could just sit in my house
and just create this, you know, fantasy land
where I got everything the way that I want it?
Like, ugh, nah.
How come also we just skipped right over,
like, social media and the way it's affecting teenagers?
What was that parlay into ignoring all of that
and the accountability
to how human beings are going to function in this world?
We're just gonna go layers deeper.
Right? And that's gonna be the crazy part.
Ten years from now,
what is gonna be the impact of social media on people?
Like, I just don't think we're designed-
Like, the way we're always looking down,
the way we see things through the lens
of social media all the time.
Like, some people can't even formulate their thoughts
until they get on social media
to see what everybody else is thinking.
That is scary.
I agree.
I know, the Meta thing-
I was like, "Wait, this is the answer?"
It's gonna be like "Avatar."
And remember at the end of "Avatar,"
that dude did not come back.
He liked living in that fantasy world.
Yeah.
Right 'cause he had Nala too.
That's what I'm saying.
I love the way you talk about the present.
I'm interested in your conversations
about where the future lies.
What is it in you-
whether it's the study of Charlamagne
and finding that name when you were younger
and the author that we're about to meet
through your imprint-
what is it about history that you find so compelling
and important to bring into the modern day with you?
Oh, well, if you don't, you know, know from what you came,
then, you know, you won't really know where you're at
and you damn sure won't know where you're going.
And you know, my mom was an English teacher,
so, like, I grew up with the Book It program
where you had to read four books to get a free pizza.
And she would always tell me,
"Read things that don't pertain to you."
So I grew up reading, like, Judy Blume and Beverly Cleary.
Oh, my God! "Nothing's Fair in Fifth Grade"?
(Charlamagne laughs)
Ramona Quimby!
"Are You There God? It's Me, Margaret."
(audience claps)
Oh, you are meant to have girls.
Oh, for real.
So, it's like, you know, I just, you know,
picked up everything growing up- like, everything.
So, I would read-
And my mom was Jehovah Witness.
I grew up Jehovah Witness, too,
so I would just read, like, my book of Bible stories.
Like, anything I could get my hands on, I would read.
So I'm just intrigued about the world, period.
I love that.
(upbeat music)